on savait que plaisir que je me trouve
devant vous ce soir s'adresser à un
public composé en grande majorité
d'élèves c'est intéressant
alors je fais évidemment le lien avec
une manifestation qui dans cette même
salle a eu lieu il y a trente ans
c'était le 11 avril 89
nous avions l'avantagé de recevoir
françois mitterrand le président de la
république qui parrainait une promotion
appelée eureka en fonction d'un grand
programme européen qu'on fait voilà donc
le plaisir que j'ai à être devant vous
et je les perspectives c'est aussi avec
des personnes que vous les faits alors
quand avant d'être élève dans cette
école entre 1952 et 1955 que c'est très
loin quand vous voyez j'avais comme
référence en quelque sorte dans mon
village du pas-de-calais de retour d'un
prêt de chez moi habitent est un ancien
élève
florent bégin qu'on ne voyait pas
souvent ou d'un parce qu'il était
directeur général des charbonnages du
ton quart en asie et est par ailleurs
dans la grande ville voisine de bruay en
artois
le maire de la ville qui était un ancien
élève aussi donc ingénieur divisionnaire
à la compagnie des mines de bruay donc
diriger une ville qui était passée d'un
d'un village de quelques centaines
d'habitants à plus de 30000 habitants
parce que dans cette région la partie
minière avait donné une explosion
il y a eu un moment deux cent cinquante
mille emplois dit
on venant de l'activité des oui hier
donc voilà c'est c'est un peu le la
trace que je voulais présenter devant
vous mais il est évident que le sujet
pour lequel j'ai souhaité intervenir et
très lié à l'actualité du débat public
et j'avoue que j'ai une petite
expérience des problèmes du débat public
qui m'a amené à m'interroger sur le
partage des connaissances nécessaires
pour avoir l'espoir qu'un débat public
puisse être utile alors j'ai une
expérience ce qui est ce qui a été fait
sur le plan technique il se fait que
dans le cadre de la constitution
française aujourd'hui il y a une
possibilité de participer aux décisions
dans le domaine de l'environnement grâce
à la commission nationale du débat
public
alors j'ai été amené dans les années
2003-2007 a coordonné trois débats elian
lieu à wavre à bordeaux et à dunkerque
sur des projets de terminaux méthaniers
et quand vous avez devant vous un
millier de personnes qui ont une opinion
bien entendu sur la perspective de voir
un terminal méthanier se construire
comment faire en sorte que les deux nés
sur l'énergie dont on vous a parlé d'une
valeur puisse servir de base au
raisonnement c'est quasiment une mission
impossible
les spécialistes du sujet
déjà dans l'emploi des unités 1 gigawatt
heure térawattheures tep joule etc
il ya une espèce d'impossibilité que
l'on rencontre de faire en sorte que les
éléments de base pour participer au
débat public puisse être dix ont mis en
place j'ai eu l'occasion de participer à
une autre commission nationale du débat
public
c'était sur une nouvelle liaison
autoroutière entre amiens lille et la
belgique et est donc là aussi il y avait
une espèce d'opposition assez forte à
avoir doublé l'autoroute a1 et je
n'oublierai jamais le désarroi du jeune
ingénieur des ponts et chaussées qui
essayait de convaincre une salle assez
hostile que ce que disait son modèle
était la vérité
donc il y à une nécessité si on veut
faire en sorte que le débat public
existe de s'interroger sur le partage
des connaissances et dans le domaine du
partage des connaissances
je suis assez convaincu que le monde des
ingénieurs et des scientifiques a une
place prépondérante à prendre dès les
écoles d'ingénieurs les étudiants
peuvent déjà à mon avis s'intéresser à
ce sujet alors là le retour d'expérience
que je fais de cette participation à des
débats publics sur des sujets techniques
environnementaux me fait dire tout
d'abord que on est amené à débattre sur
des sujets qui peuvent être difficiles
et on peut toujours s'interroger est ce
que c'est vraiment utile
mon expérience de ces débats publics me
fait dire que c'est toujours utile
ça n'est pas toujours totalement
satisfaisant les résultats ne sont pas
toujours aussi construit qu'on le
souhaiterait mais je n'ai pas connu de
débats publics pour lesquels on puisse
se dire va tout est négatif ça servi à
rien etc
alors pour prendre un exemple délicat
pour le ministère de l'environnement
il ya eu un grand débat public à
l'échelon national sur les
nanotechnologies et là le débat a tourné
court parce qu'un certain nombre
d'associations se sont opposés à la
tenue du débat donc alors on peut dans
ce cas se dire que le débat n'a servi à
rien mais mais même là on est en droit
de se dire que les différents acteurs
dans le domaine des nanotechnologies et
ils sont nombreux en termes de
ministères ya et 1,7 ministère dans tout
gouvernement intéressés à une
nanotechnologie son saut pour le moins
obligé de se concerter pour définir une
parole commune
est ce assez c'est loin d'être
négligeable
alors c'est un peu ce que je retiens de
donc de ce débat public en ayant aussi
l'idée que le partage des connaissances
et difficile certains pourraient être
tentés de dire impossible et le recours
vers l' expertise des experts peut être
aux yeux de certains une une solution
une voie de sortie alors faire partager
les paroles d'expert ça ne sera jamais
plus simple que de faire partager les
connaissances donc c'est un peu un faux
débat que d'opposer en quelque sorte
connaissance et
parole d'expert alors dans les médias
dans tout débat joue un rôle important
et on peut hein peut s'interroger sur le
fait que dans les médias y est parfois
des journalistes spécialisés des
journalistes scientifiques des
spécialistes du droit etc
et si vous regardez un petit peu ce qui
se passe la tendance dans notre monde
aujourd'hui c'est que les journalistes
spécialisés sont de moins en moins
nombreux mais on on se réfugie dans des
choses certainement plus plus générale
et quand on offre up aux élus la
possibilité de rentrer davantage dans
les choix technologiques que doit faire
tout pays
on est obligé de constater que c'est pas
très facile il ya dans notre pays
un office parlementaire des choix
scientifiques et technologiques et on
voit bien que les les élus d'une manière
générale ont délégué à quelques
spécialistes la salle la participation à
cette structure donc s'attaquer au
partage des connaissances pour faciliter
les vapes unique n'est certainement pas
très simple il faut peut-être accepté de
faire preuve d'un peu d'utopie
alors c'est un peu ce que je vais faire
devant vous en vous disant que j'ai eu
l'occasion de fréquenter ce qui dans la
fonction publique constituent les corps
d'inspection inspections générales des
finances inspection générale des
affaires sociales et sanitaires corps
des ponts je sais corps des mines etc et
on trouve dans ces personnes qui ont
reçu une formation et ex assez
remarquable et on fait des tâches
d'exécution au bénéfice du gouvernement
ont tous des personnes qui sont
peut-être capable de s'intéresser au
partage des connaissances à à la
condition d'accepter de travailler
avec d'autres structures et je pense à
des structures associatives du type atd
quart monde
le secours populaire le secours
catholique et que la croix rouge etc
si on arrivait en quelque sorte à faire
travailler ensemble des hauts
fonctionnaires très connaisseur de leur
domaine avec des bases scientifiques
forme n'est pas économique et et des
personnes connaissant bien le monde
disons réels du terrain et sert à on
pourrait peut-être un jour mettre à la
disposition des citoyens de notre pays
donc des cahiers que j'aurais tendance à
appeler de la démocratie participative
parce que on a besoin d'outils et
d'outils qui plus est ce qu'ils puissent
être en quelque sorte présenté à
l'ensemble des citoyens
c'est c'est des choses qui manquent
aujourd'hui quand vous lisez eux on vous
a longuement parlé de l'accès à
l'information
il est certain que si on veut que nos
concitoyens puissent s'intéresser à des
problèmes un peu complexes et les
problèmes sont dans notre société de
plus en plus complexes il faut mettre en
place des moyens d'une certaine forme de
pédagogie
alors pour imaginer que des cahiers de
la démocratie participative puisse
exister
je m'appuie un peu ce une expérience
fort modeste mais qui a joué un rôle
important
il ya une cinquantaine d'années un
organisme qui s'appelle l'union féminine
civique et sociale du fcs s'est mis dans
dans la tête de faire en sorte que les
femmes participent davantage aux
associations aux communaux activité
d'élue et c est cette organisation avait
mise au point des cahiers
et donc d'information civique qui année
après année ont permis à des personnes
d'avoir les bases nécessaires pour
devenir des élus etc
donc il ya une possibilité et il y à des
personnes ouvertes à ce type de débat
même dans la dans la haute fonction
publique pour prendre un exemple qui
m'est assez cher il ya un inspecteur
général des finances qui a créé il ya
trente ans donc snc solidarités
nouvelles face au chômage
en dix ans il ya trente ans qu'il
fallait se préoccuper du chômage d'une
autre manière qu'on le faisait jusqu'à
présent et c'est donc voilà un
inspecteur général des finances donc
jean baptiste de foucauld pour le nommer
a appris cette disons cet engagement
qu'il tient toujours etc
et il ya 2000 équipe en france qui
travaille avec ces bases là de la même
manière si vous voulez on peut on peut
se dire que dans nos grandes écoles
aujourd'hui il y à un mouvement qui
conduit à faire en sorte que les
étudiants travaillent avec le milieu
associatif et ça c'est dans la formation
quelque chose qu'il peut se développer
qui existe déjà et j'avoue que pour
avoir suivi notamment dans cette école
des étudiants qui sont allés parler avec
les gens qui fréquentent les restos du
coeur de problèmes d'énergie
ils ont vu après d'une manière toute
autre les problèmes d'énergie
cette relation avec des des associations
très très engagé auprès des plus démunis
conduit à faire prendre en compte par
les futurs cadres donc des données
sociales qui ne
qui ne peuvent pas s'inventer qu'on fait
alors j'en profite pour dire que on voit
bien tout à l'heure il a été évoqué la
frugalité en matière énergétique est
elle est vrai aussi cette donnée dans le
domaine technologique
tous les ingénieurs que nous formons
rêve de bourrée de technologie
tous les appareils pour une utilité qui
est souvent quand même un petit peu
reste rate donc il ya une espèce
d'éducation peut-être à la frugalité
technologique qui dont on peut espérer
qu'elle puisse se développer comme étant
alors il est évident que si on veut
faire des choses totalement nouvelle
dans le domaine de la démocratie
participative
il faut s'interroger aussi sur le
travail des chercheurs
alors j'aurais tendance à penser que le
conservatoire national des arts et
métiers à dans le domaine dans les
domaines nouveaux à savoir faire qui y
est à signaler
il y à quelques dizaines d'années quand
on a voulu s'intéresser dans notre pays
au travail social on s'est aperçu que
toutes les recherches étaient dans
beaucoup de disciplines pour les réunir
en une seule
on a créé une chaire du travail social
au conservatoire national des arts et
métiers
alors j'imagine qu'on pourrait
aujourd'hui créée au conservatoire
national des arts et métiers donc une
chaire de la démocratie participative
alors ça veut dire que les chercheurs et
tout ça ça intéresse forcément les
personnes qui font des études
supérieures le monde de la recherche
mais si on veut avoir une action longue
en profondeur il faut évidemment mettre
en place une autre autorité que celle de
l'état il ya eu des exemples tout à
l'heure pour montrer que l'état
a toujours un peu tendance à aa a donné
les choses telles qu'elles lui plaisent
et c'est donc il existe dans notre pays
des autorités administratives
indépendantes
c'est vrai dans le domaine du nucléaire
c'est vrai dans le domaine de
l'audiovisuel
ces autorités administratives
indépendantes sans être parfaite
permettent quand même de développer une
action de long terme
alors on peut imaginer que si on voulait
avoir une
un développement d'une certaine forme de
démocratie participative une autorité
administrative pourrait être constituée
et faire en sorte que on travaille sur
le long terme
alors tout ça évidemment correspond à
l'idée que la seule démocratie
disons représentative qui est la note
aujourd'hui ne pourra pas rester seul
qu'il faudra y associer une démocratie
participative
c'est un peu ce qui se réfléchit
aujourd'hui au passage dans le grand
débat national qui va devoir lieu la
présence des jeunes et des étudiants n'a
pas été très forte
c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire donc et
c'est tout ça ça veut dire qu'il faut
changer un peu un peu les choses et
l'échangé en en acceptant de regarder
avec des yeux un peu neuf
le problème ça ça ne veut pas dire pour
autant qu'il ne faille pas conserver ou
à ce qui existe aujourd'hui un rôle
fondamental
et bien entendu si on veut des citoyens
plus fort mais dans notre pays
l'école reste l'élément majeur l'école
système public tel qu'il existe bien
entendu
alors il faut aussi s'interroger sur les
l'outil internet dont on dit bien sûr le
plus grand bien c'est un outil
remarquable mais comment faire en sorte
que tout le monde est taxé à ce moyen
si on veut partager les connaissances et
il faut certainement savoir mieux
utiliser les outils que représente
disons les réseaux sociaux
l'informatique etc
alors vous savez que aujourd'hui on
chiffre à 14 millions de français
le nombre de ceux qui sont hors jeu en
informatique 14 millions il ya 47
millions d'électeurs dans notre pays
alors alors tout ceci donc peut-être
regarder
et puis en regardant aussi dans un
domaine on revient vers les écoles
d'ingénieurs celui du domaine du partage
des connaissances dans les domaines
scientifiques
les choses ne vont pas d'elle-même
partager les connaissances scientifiques
ça n'est pas si simple donc ça nous
amène à être modeste
quand on veut partager les connaissances
pour le débat public
voilà ce que je souhaitais vous dire
merci
[Applaudissements]